it is day three of the impeachment trial
you're looking live at the Senate floor
where house impeachment managers are
desperately trying to convince the
Senate to throw Trump out of office but
so far Adam Schiff and his friends
haven't been able to move the needle
Democrats claim they have a slam-dunk
home run case the Republicans aren't
buying it take a look mr. Schiff and the
other managers did an exceptional job
laying out the facts this is the weakest
case for impeachment in the history of
this country we continue to see how
flimsy this case is the president's
conduct is wrong it is illegal it is
dangerous who shouldn't be trusted is
Adam Schiff and the house managers that
are trying to perpetrate this lie on the
American people and while Democrats will
spend 24 hours going after Trump Adam
Chef revealed what impeachment is really
all about we are here today to consider
a much more grave matter and that is an
attempt to use the powers of the
presidency to cheat in an election for
precisely this reason the president's
misconduct cannot be decided at the
ballot box for we cannot be assured that
the vote will be fairly won Dana I was
reading Karl Rove today great way to
start your day I always start my day
with a little robe and he had a great
point I've made this point many times
but I guess he made it in the Wall
Street Journal so it's very very
official we were just talking about it
what what if Hillary Clinton had become
president and then we'd found out she'd
paid for this dossier overseas to dirty
up her political opponent would the
Democrats have wanted to impeach her for
paying for foreign election interference
surely not definitely not I rest my case
you can go back to regular scheduled
business no and Karl's column is always
good in wall street journal' I think
today when he when he can zero in on
politics like this and make the point
but basically that it would have come
out because the whole issue of Carter
page and his surveillance and all the
spices stuff it was going to come out
either way
and yes we've established at hypocrisy
as well at hand people who had one
position in 1999 have a different
position now and if the shoes were on
the other feet then we know what would
happen do you want to mention one thing
Adam Schiff and his cohorts there have
continued to use this phrase that the
president was trying to cheat in an
election the Republicans when they had
the chance in opening statements on
Tuesday repeated several times that the
Democrats are trying to steal an
election so I'm just wondering if you're
at home and cheating and stealing in
elections and it gets to be a little bit
confusing and I think you know the
numbers show that the ratings are not
great for all of this and people are
sort of paying attention not much people
are pretty tribal on it they've heard
this for a long time and I talked to a
House Democrat who said they think Adam
Schiff did a great job but they also
know that this is going nowhere and
they'd like to get back to business
well you know what I was thinking about
earlier today if Biden hadn't bragged on
camera that he fired the prosecutor
investigating his son I don't think
president Trump would have ever even
known to ask the Ukrainians to look into
the corruption what difference does that
make that Biden is responsible for it no
I think Trump is always going to be
looking for something and in fact I
think this is the heart of the matter
that you heard presented by Adam Schiff
yesterday that you can't just say that
this is about something that happened in
the past that the president persist in
saying it was a perfect call there's
nothing wrong he's tell he's told
interviewers with seeking a foreign
country to intervene in our election to
his benefit that's the way he so what
you heard from Adam Schiff yesterday was
literally saying you know we have to be
aware this is an ongoing issue but I
think the big story to my mind by the
way I think the ratings numbers have
been surprisingly good for something is
taking place largely in the middle of
the day you know people are paying
attention maybe it's not a sensation you
know it's not pro wrestling but you know
what for something as serious and as
requiring of attention as this I think
it's pretty good but I think the big
news here over the last two days is
Republicans said hey why do we need
witnesses if Democrats say they've made
a compelling case with their two
articles of impeachment and what we've
seen from shift yesterday which even
Republican
like Lindsey Graham said was a very good
job and now today from Jerry Nadler and
Sylvia Garcia are just compelling
narratives about why this president in
fact on the basis of facts and evidence
deserves to be impeached their word
facts I think is an interesting one and
all of that Adam Schiff and all of the
other impeachment managers from the
house on the Democrat side have had the
luxury this week to talk for hours on
end without being contested by anyone
without being questioned like we see in
regular Senate hearings so they can
really say whatever they want and call
it facts when there is a rebuttal coming
that we were waiting for from the White
House but on the hunter Biden narrative
it's been made the argument that
President Trump was simply going after
hunter Biden or Joe Biden because they
wanted to score political points or gain
some kind of advantage in the election
the White House has repeatedly argued it
was about corruption and the argument
has been that it's only President Trump
well the Obama White House also had very
serious questions about hunter Biden's
position on the verismo board while Vice
President Joe Biden was had the Ukraine
portfolio and was working on foreign
policy State Department officials who
testified as Democrat witnesses we're
hearing a lot about witnesses that
record has been entered into the Senate
for everyone to see they have repeatedly
said that per risen was a problem
it was notoriously corrupt and there
were very serious questions about why
Joe Biden's son was earning a lot of
money at the same time that there was a
conflict of interest in the White House
while he was running for him a lot of
minot greg gutfeld money but money
nonetheless yeah you started this
segment by saying you're looking live at
the center at the Senate floor no you're
looking dead did you notice that they
were already showing videos that they
showed yesterday so they're already into
their summer reruns and but it doesn't
matter because all they're trying to do
is fill space this is basically so far a
three day campaign ad against Trump and
it would be this would be a great time
for the news to actually do the to the
fact-checking to say Adam Schiff is
saying this because the the reason why
people say Adams have sucks and Adam
Schiff did a great job is because Adam
Schiff is presenting a
and so people who disagree with the
opinion say he's bad and people who
agree with his opinion say he's dazzling
so we know it's all opinion the problem
is we have all these fact checkers and
amazing journalists and they're just
overloaded with atoms ship that they
can't fact check what he's doing so
instead what do they do they discuss his
performance not the content but the
performance oh he really laid it out
there what do you mean tell me did you
tell me what can you tell me what he
laid out and whether or not it was true
or false the most telling moment was
that sound on tape that you played when
Schiff said impeachment is necessary
because we can't can't count on 20/20
being I'm a legitimate election so think
about that he is saying that impeachment
as a process is superior to an election
not just passed once in 2016 but future
ones okay so it's not so what he's
basically saying is that anybody can do
this and he's saying this to prevent a
future event this is a figment in his
brain it's not even real he's saying the
2020 election cannot be trusted that had
the 20/20 alleged has not even happened
yet so we've seen this before with the
meeting with the Democrats their
arguments are always about the future
because the reality is so different than
what what their experience the reality
in the United States is great the
economy the stock market we have peace
of prosperity so they have to look ahead
and predict the apocalypse in order to
somehow keep Trump in their crosshairs
but it's not about the thing is they
know it's gonna be acquitted right they
know he's not gonna he's not going to be
impeached so we know we all know it's
not about impeachment
it's about wounding this thing is
actually effective because it's wounding
him so that it will be a bother it will
be a burden for him come election so
they already know they're not gonna
they're not gonna impeach the guy but
they do know that this is something that
will be stuck on him until the lammeter
just quickly respond and to say that I
think that fact checkers are locked in
and what we're seeing is that the
biggest fact checkers are at the White
House and they're in front of the
microphones and there are Republicans
who say this is the problem where this
isn't the problem you know what they're
not saying hey ship is factually wrong
they're saying we don't like the
process there was a secret proceeding in
the House Democrats there were people
they said it was factually no we
presented that fake messages argue about
the ship by the way
something happened in 2016 and today
there was more presentation saying yes
Russia interferes and 26 cents a benefit
Donald Trump and Donald Trump asked for
their help
yep so Trump cheated in 2016 and he's
gonna cheat again in 2013
don't worry there you got the word
speech over-worried
input so you can help from the you way
it's a democrat economist at least you
didn't pay for it like crooked Oh get
out